we're going to begin with rams packers
sharing you have someone from the rams
yeah you know mike it would be easy to
pick aaron donald and i think he's
instrumental for them in this game he's
got to play well despite that rib injury
that he that he has
but i'm going to go with cam akers
because jared goff needs help as we
talked about
and cam akers is the guy to help him
they've got to keep the ball
out of aaron rodgers hands cam akers is
the guy to do that
and i think he he can do that he showed
it last week 28 carries 131 yards and a
touchdown he also caught two passes
for 45 yards he's really coming on and
played well but if you think back to the
rams super bowl year
remember in the divisional round mike
when they played the cowboys
they had cj anderson off the couch and
todd gurley
and they rushed for 273 yards against
the cowboys i think they're going to
have to have
some sort of game like that rushing the
ball to have a chance against the
packers
i think you're absolutely right and as
we discussed earlier as it relates to
jared goff whether it's goff whether
it's acres whether it's somebody else
that offense needs to step
up because if the defense is going to
have any luck against the packers and
holding them down
the offense still has to score some
points i'm going to go to that green bay
offense i already mentioned aaron jones
and the fact that they need him and they
need him to run the ball they need him
to catch the ball out of the backfield
they need him to take some heat off of
devante adams and aaron rodgers
and they they are are uh going to
potentially
desperately need aaron jones if jaylen
ramsey is able to neutralize devante
adams so to me he is such a key player
in this game
and i think other than aaron rodgers and
i could have said devante adams but i'm
assuming
ramsay is just going to take him away so
you you cross out ramsey you cross out
adams
what can aaron jones do shireen yeah i
think it's aaron jones and robert tonya
needs to have a good game too
mike but aaron jones did it last year in
the postseason he had three touchdowns
in two games and
didn't go over a hundred yards but was
really effective running the ball he
needs to do that again for the packers
to have a chance
the saturday night game on nbc the
ravens
and the bills shireen from the buffalo
side of things
who's the most important on quarterback
well we talked about
zach moss being out with that ankle
injury mike and so it falls on devin
singletary and
and of course josh allen as we've said
is going to run the ball
some but devin singletary really needs
to have a good game tj yeldon will be
their other running back
uh in that game we saw singletary's
yards per carry drop
from 5-1 to 4-4 this season he was down
a little bit
but in the three games that zach moss
didn't play this year
he was outstanding 42 carries 152 yards
and a touchdown and 10 catches for 79
yards and a touchdown
he's ready to be the workhorse running
back mike
and they need him to do that with
especially if the weather conditions
aren't very good in that game if there's
some snow we know it's going to be cold
no matter if there's snow or not
last time i checked the dark sky app
which is an excellent worldwide weather
predictor it looked like things were
going to be fine from a precipitation
standpoint
i kind of like some snow in the air but
i don't want it to affect the game
i think that marlon humphrey the ravens
cornerback can affect the game in a
positive way for the ravens if they
assign him to stefan diggs
most of the time all the time a lot of
the time
they need to take away stefan diggs sims
and i were talking about this earlier in
the week i would
and and this is where it becomes
interesting i don't know do you put
marlon humphrey one on one on
someone else and double staphon diggs
with jimmy smith or marcus peters plus
safety help i don't know but either way
humphrey's gonna have to lock someone
down
whether it's diggs or someone else they
need that defensive secondary to step up
and humphrey is the leader of that unit
he's the guy that got the big contract
and they need to take away the passing
game or at least minimize it if they're
going to have a chance
to outscore the buffalo bills and we'll
see if humphrey or
the rest of the defensive backfield for
the ravens can pull that off
brown's chiefs shireen who uh who
wait uh this is i i don't need more than
half a guess
to know who you're picking from the
cleveland browns
of course it's miles garrett he needs to
have a big game you know he's going
back-to-back games without a
sack mike and he said he's ready for a
big game he needs to have it this week
he's not been the same guy since his
return from covid
and he's talked a lot about that how the
breathing hasn't come back it's really
affected him
in the six games since he's come back
from covet only two and a half sacks
three tackles for loss four quarterback
hits he's got to do more than that
against patrick mahomes and we know how
mahomes just keeps floating back and
back and back making it hard to sack him
he was only sacked 22 times in the
regular season
so it's very difficult thing to do but
he needs to somehow affect
patrick mahomes and that chief's
passing game or the browns just have
zero chance in this game and i think
they are i think they're going to have a
good defensive performance this week
i'm going with travis kelsey from the
chiefs the tight end and you could have
gone tyree kill
yeah yeah but but i travis kelsey for a
couple of reasons number one he's that
guy that's always open he's that guy
that patrick mahomes is always looking
for he's that guy that really fuels the
meat and potatoes of the passing game
tyree kill is the is the sizzle in the
steak and travis kelsey is more like the
you know the gristle in the middle and
the mashed potatoes and everything that
goes along with keeping it moving in the
right direction
and he grew up in cleveland which makes
this one a little more special for him
to take on the brown so i'll go kelsey
last game of the weekend
buccaneers saints the quarterbacks are
going to be critical
who's the most important non-quarterback
for the buccaneers
well you know i was going to pick the
other aggie mike right it's mike evans
of course and he needs to have a big
game and he hasn't had a big game
because they lock him down with marshawn
lattimore and he has no touchdowns
against marshawn lattimore since 2018
he has not played well against the
saints
one catch two yards and a touchdown in
week one four catches 64 yards and no
touchdowns in week nine
they have to have him be very involved
in this game mike like he was last week
against washington
i've got taysom hill from the saints for
one very important reason bruce aryan
said in the aftermath of their win over
washington
he wanted alex smith not taylor heineke
to play quarterback because he was
concerned about the defense's ability to
deal with the mobility
of heineken and he warned the defense
about it and they still got burned by
him so
drew brees isn't mobile taysom hill is
and this is the opportunity for the
saints to unleash taysom hill
and maybe maybe have him have a big
impact on that game we're gonna answer
some of your best questions when pftpm
continues right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports